[Music]
6 25 on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy how about some ramp
closure love
in and around mesquite so the axis ii
mesquite from the i-15 are going to be
closed during daylight hours this week
part of the ongoing repaving project
there now to be clear the exits are not
going to be closed at the same time
started an hour ago falcon ridge parkway
until 5 this evening that's exit 120
for tomorrow and for wednesday from 5am
to 5pm the ramps to and from
exit 122 that sandhill and pioneer
boulevards
even then endow calls the closures
intermittent so think of it as a heads
up you you may not have any issues at
all getting on or off the freeways in
mesquite but it's better to be prepared
just follow the signs
now the project does include new asphalt
on both directions the i-15
repairing resurfacing the freeway bridge
decks it also calls for new signs
drainage and lighting they're doing the
work in two mile increments on mondays
through friday so please buckle up drive
carefully and put on that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
you can email me with pictures and video
to traffic 8 at 8 news now dot com